what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really exciting
news about the Scarlet Witch and the
supernatural side of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now we've been
talking about this Supernatural side for
quite some time now especially recently
since more developments have been
happening on this side of the MCU with
movies like blade coming up of course we
had werewolf By Night the Disney plus
special presentation and Agatha coven of
chaos is coming up as well and we've
learned a bit of information about this
series already and of course we have
been hearing big talks about Mephisto we
have more developments about that that
we're going to be talking about today
but we are going to specifically be
talking about Opry Plaza's character and
how it's recently been reported that she
is going to be appearing in more
projects and Marvel has offered her a
multi-project deal plus not to mention
the Scarlet Witch Solo movie it looks
like the MCU could be building up to
Aubry Plaza character going up against
the Scarlet Witch and based off of what
we know so far the Scarlet Witch Wanda
will actually not be as powerful as
Aubry Plaza's character which is quite
interesting to think about considering
how strong she was and Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness and how she is
basically the strongest character in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe already but
reports tell us that Aubry Plaza's
character when she enters is going to be
stronger however do not expect a Scarlet
Witch vs Aubry Plaza's character and of
course we're going to talk about who
that is or could be but don't expect
that Face-Off in Agatha coven of chaos
remember what Marvel Studios likes to do
with their Disney Plus shows they like
to keep them about the main characters
I'm sure everybody can recall back to
the one division times where we thought
the finale was going to include perhaps
Doctor Strange perhaps Magneto theories
went crazy of course I contributed to
them but to be fair Paul Bettany did
troll Us by stating there's a big a
cameo in the finale which ended up being
himself but in the end it was about
Wanda AKA The Scarlet Witch vision and
Agatha so the same will go for Agatha
coven of chaos it's going to focus on
the characters that they're going to
introduce in the show and from what
we've heard the Scarlet Witch probably
isn't going to be showing up in the show
there are rumors that she might appear
in one episode and I would be surprised
if she's not at least mentioned after
all at the end of one division she did
put Agatha in that sort of mental prison
so it would be kind of weird if the
Scarlet Witch isn't even at least
mentioned but going into Wanda's solo
story in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
her story is not yet done even Kevin
feige said in response to people asking
if Wanda AKA The Scarlet Witch was
really dead if she really died at the
end of Doctor Strange in the
multi-person madness he said that when
windigore Mountain Came Crashing Down
you could see that little red light
spark and that's all he said he said I'm
gonna leave it at that but we all know
what that means Wanda's not dead she got
a away after all we saw how strong she
was in Multiverse of Madness she's the
most powerful being in our universe at
least and some crumbling rocks aren't
exactly going to kill her that would
honestly be kind of dumb but what is in
store for her well the new story for the
Scarlet Witch is going to start an
Agatha coven of chaos remember in one
division Agatha said that Wanda is the
Scarlet Witch and she is not supposed to
exist but the dark hole did talk about
her so we know in this series Marvel is
going to go over kind of the past of
Agatha Harkness her old coven and
possibly her new coven what we do know
is this project is going to be extremely
important for the MCU moving forward and
that Marvel has actually taken pretty
strict precautions to make sure none of
this really gets out and we know this
because some plot details were revealed
by a cast member by Patti LuPone and she
may have thought that these details
weren't that important and didn't really
give anything away but of course they do
one she revealed that we should expect
some a bag of the coven of chaos to be a
musical there's going to be some songs
performed whatever that doesn't really
spoil anything however what she did
reveal was her character she said that
she is playing the role of a
450 year old Sicilian witch who has the
power of divination and she says her
character is part of a coven led by
Catherine Hans Agatha Harkness now this
actually really does matter and it
matters for the Scarlet Witch because
what this tells us is that some of these
witches are really really old centuries
old and right now a lot of talk is
happening about Aubry Plaza's character
and we know that she plays and I finger
quote here a witch in Agatha's coven
however a lot of what the Insiders are
saying points to her not actually being
a witch but more than likely being a
super powerful being maybe Mephisto now
we've talked about this briefly but
deadline reported that Sasha bear Cohen
in the Iron Heart series is most likely
playing Mephisto so recently when The
Insider started to hint that Aubry Plaza
might be playing Mephisto it was kind of
confusing but then we heard that Aubry
Plaza's character could appear in many
different forms so she could still be
Mephisto if not she is an ultra powerful
being who eventually is going to run
into the Scarlet Witch so expect her
character to be extremely old possibly
centuries old and this is why she is
going to be so powerful Wanda has
discovered the dark hold yes and she is
kind of starting to get control over her
powers however she doesn't have
centuries of time under her belt
practicing her powers perfecting
everything all of the Spells gaining
knowledge of other types of magic that
she could perhaps perform when Aubry
Plaza's character most likely has this
is why now some insiders are saying that
Aubry Plaza's character is stronger than
the Scarlet Witch and it does make sense
and according to Insider Alex P from the
cosmic circus Aubry Plaza's character
and the Scarlet Witch will meet and
Aubry Plaza is going to appear in
multiple projects this is what Alex P
had to say online in response to this
tweet that said if we don't get any
Wanda Lizzy Aubry interactions in Marvel
future I say we riot in which Alex
stated Oh They'll meet not in Coven of
chaos so temper your expectations but
Plaza is here to stay it's not a one and
done deal with her then it was The
Insider can we get some toast that
stated on paper Aubry Plaza's character
in Coven of chaos should be stronger
than even the Scarlet Witch then Insider
Daniel rpk came out and said no idea who
she's playing it's a huge secret my
sources couldn't tell me they only told
me she's a big deal to Marvel comic
readers and even non-comic book readers
will know that character and that's
really really interesting it's really
interesting to know that Marvel Studios
really is trying to keep this a secret
and Patti LuPone did say that she did
get in trouble by Marvel security they
talked to her about what she said and
said she can't say anything anymore but
she did say they were nice but
ultimately I think this is going to lead
up to a big Showdown when the Scarlet
Witch and Aubry Plaza's character who I
do believe could be Mephisto that is a
character that comic book Raiders are
definitely going to know but if you're
not a comic book character it's easy to
describe a creature as sort of the devil
which is something regardless of
whatever your beliefs are you know of
people know what demons and devils are
so signs point to Mephisto but even if
not it does seem like this character is
going to be a main villain of the
Scarlet Witch possibly the main villain
of her solo story yes Elizabeth Olsen
has said that she's not really sure what
Marvel Studios has going on she has said
that she would love to return but what
we know from inside information is that
her solo story is in development and why
wouldn't they do it everybody loves the
Scarlet Witch and she does need a solo
movie not a show a movie and her
character Arc does need to kind of be
not finished because obviously we want
to see more of her but picked up again
we can't just end it on wundergore
Mountain plus we know she's going to
appear in secret Wars as well but with
the supernatural side of the MCU about
to be a pretty big deal and each side of
the MCU having its own dedicated villain
it's looking like our story arcs are
leading up to Mephisto being that
villain and the Scarlet Witch having to
take on Mephisto and comic book readers
know that there is so much history with
Mephisto and the Scarlet Witch I mean
her children in the comics were shards
of mephisto's soul and Mephisto ended up
taking them away Mephisto literally took
Wanda's kids away from her which is why
we thought that was going to happen in
one division we thought Mephisto could
be the actual parents of Billy and Tommy
but here's the thing in the comics the
kids come back kind of like
reincarnation but this story is also
kind of what leads to House of M with
Wanda kind of going crazy so there's
just so much story to be had in the MCU
with Wanda slash the Scarlet Witch and
Mephisto or at least a very powerful
demon who they could simply hint as
Mephisto maybe not actually call him
that but heavily imply and we've been
told that this character can take many
different forms so Aubry Plaza could be
Mephisto and one thing and Sasha bear
Cohen could play Mephisto in another
show but since Alex P from the cosmic
circus said that this deal for Aubry
Plaza and the MCU is not one and done
implying it's a multi-project deal I'm
assuming the main form of this demon
slash Mephisto is going to be Aubry
Plaza plus not to mention Fisto really
does have connections with almost every
hero but he does have big connections to
doctor strange and Dr Doom and I'm
assuming that doctor strange and the
Scarlet Witch are going to have to team
up eventually and that's most likely
going to start with the King Dynasty in
secret Wars and again this is a story
that needs to be completed Wanda is a
villain we don't want her to end that
way we want her to be a hero but when
Wanda helps The Avengers with King
Dynasty in secret Wars it's gonna be
kind of awkward after all she killed a
lot of sorcerers so it's probably not
just going to be super cool with Wong
and a lot of other people that she is
now just fighting with the Avengers
helping them but isn't really facing any
repercussions so that is definitely
going to have to be addressed in the
future and I'm assuming it'll be
addressed when Wanda finally gets her
solo movie I do think this is going to
be a big build up to a big battle
between Aubry Plaza's character and
Wanda and I do believe other people are
going to get involved I think Agatha is
going to actually side with Wanda once
she realizes who Aubry Plaza's character
is we've been told that Agatha in the
show isn't good or bad she's kind of
just her own thing in the middle does
what she wants but she's not gonna like
that another so-called Witch is stronger
than her especially when the Scarlet
Witch is stronger than her so she'll
align with the Scarlet Witch to take out
the more powerful witch and then of
course I think Doctor Strange has to get
involved as well this is what he deals
with and ultimately the midnight Suns
team will come into the MCU and perhaps
they'll take on Mephisto as well but for
now it looks like Wanda is going to be
going up against Aubry Plaza's character
eventually in the future who is most
likely Mephisto but of course if we hear
anything else anything official we'll be
sure to do an update video on this so be
sure to hit that subscribe button and
hit that notification Bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
please don't forget to like the video
and leave a comment and subscribe if you
want to enter our giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 Marvel
Legends items or some DC items as well
the winner gets the pick when we pick a
winner at the end of each month also we
are on patreon now where we post
exclusive content and if you feel like
supporting the channel it would be
greatly appreciated you can type in the
cosmic Wonder on patreon or click the
link in the description down below we
also have our website up and running now
as well we post a lot of news on there
and feel free to follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
foreign